[Music]
four four why
perugia that's what that was like my big
thing when i was watching i was like why
not
venice why not tuscany so there's a
sister city association with perugia in
seattle
so like the the reason why perugia was
such a
a nice place to do that is because they
had developed between the uw
and the and the university that persia
program that was like a friendship
program
um so people from it just made it very
easy to like they made it easy for you
to sign up for classes basically and
that's why
um a small town in the middle of italy
um i didn't even realize there was
another university there i thought it
was supposed to be like a small town
vibe
and i felt like a small town vibe was
going to be better for me to learn the
language because
i figured i've been to places like tokyo
or berlin
i know that when you're there a lot of
people speak english and yeah you are
and they want to practice english on you
and it's like i'm not here i didn't
cross the world
my english is better than your german so
can we just get this
here right i need to like find the
bathroom
i don't want to like work to like find
out when i need to pee and
that was not like in italy i was going
for small town where there weren't going
to be many tourists because i genuinely
wanted to just like
immerse myself in italian people and
that was out of a genuine love for
italian people
so pathogen avoidance circling back
because i forgot
so when we uh the uh fear of a robot or
a scarecrow or
doll i talked about this a little bit
with robert green like dolls do creep me
out creep but clowns
is um when something looks human but
doesn't behave
like a human and i think the reason why
dolls freak me out even more is because
they're children
and like i'm always in makeup in like
weird
drag makeup yeah just like i can't take
care of you
and yeah and like there's like your eye
lashes
are those from what are the eyelashes
made of yeah
i just want to know what animal died for
this creepy fucking
doll um uh but pathogen avoidance if we
see something that looks human but
doesn't move like a human
the dissonance it stresses us out to
stop us from fucking corpses
which have guys
um what were you guys what were you
saying so that the fear of holes
um and like when people see close-ups of
human skin
they can be really freaked out by all
the pores and we were hypothesizing the
other days
try hypophobia it's a i think that's it
yeah
a fear of like at the normal human scale
of perception
you don't see things with many holes
that way unless you have like
gaping wounds or sores or festering you
know like
so it's a disease avoidance thing
leprosy yeah
yeah and i love popping zits which i've
talked about
i also love popping sets she does it
without consent though
yeah no i have learned to not i do
i do with x's i'm like can i just get
that like i cannot
handle it um so i have a
uh i think that goes back to like
grooming oh yeah yeah
yeah ejecting uh bacteria from the body
et cetera et cetera
um
interesting that i wrote down okay so
why is it
that when ted the ted bundy tapes came
out i
listened to them and ted bundy does a
movie and we watch it
and ted but like why isn't ted bundy
cancel
like why do actual convicted murderers
get to have 50 shows
and be celebrities and
uh comedians don't get to say
tell rape jokes that's not i know that's
a big
pandora's box but it's like
you have to have done it
to speak knowledgeably about you know
what i mean i listened to the ted bundy
tapes
on netflix i gave i don't know who got
that money
but joe berlinger but can i who's that
he's the director oh copy that am i i i
can't listen to r kelly
i can't listen to um
michael jackson i can't watch kevin
spacey movies but i can watch
the ted bundy tapes in mine hunter
um i think that's because we um we
want to understand extremes and
so i think we're drawn yeah we're drawn
to black and white
and i think it also kind of goes back i
mean at least
from a woman's perspective you're going
i could have loved this man
and ted bundy had a wife that he did not
kill right
absolutely and when i'm such a like
it's the wolf and shit people are really
drawn to
and terrified of the idea that the
person who looks really pleasant
and really nice and kind um
the ted bundy or the amanda knox it
could be anyone
and they are sometimes they're handsome
yep sometimes they yup yup yup and it
also like isn't like you don't have this
sort of satisfying like oh you know
he grew up in a bad home and he was like
you know it's always
always the mom's fault right always the
mom put painting there's a whole show
about like psychopaths moms or something
like that it's always the mom's fault
she just didn't do
anything right it's not what about your
moms has there been a day
where you like forgot you were amanda
knox for the day
like one day where you just like got
through the day maybe your wedding day
or something where you were just like
no i did not get to do that on my
wedding day because they were paparazzi
that were tmz yeah like the day before
my wedding
um we got like the guy in the office
that's like the
no like the the guy who owned the elks
lodge where we
bummer we were at like called me in and
he was like oh my god i hope i didn't do
anything wrong and i was like what
happened and he was like well
uh this tmz called and i and they asked
if
your wedding was happening and i said
it's a private event and
like he was in bless him i didn't like i
i thought that we had done a good enough
job to like not let them
figure this out um i don't know how they
figured out that it was an elks lodge of
all places
space themed wedding yeah um incorrect
though
it's not even space theme they were just
like postulating based on
what people regardless it's good to see
amanda and chris came full circle with
their love
for the otherworldly they got engaged
with a full-blown
et recreation i love it how people were
like
making assumptions about what it was
based on like their
what they saw through their
long-distance lenses and
no no context whatsoever it was not the
one time convicted fallon it's just like
one yeah yeah i'm the acquitted the
acquitted person yeah
but these are words like words fucking
like boom yep adrenaline yeah adrenaline
turns into dopamine and they know that
yeah once convicted is a the safe way
like the i can't sue you way
of saying you called me convicted when
i've never sued anyone
i have attempted i've got looked into
suing people
and consistently across the board i
it's never ever worth the amount of
money that i would have to put into
fighting it and it would take years and
it would honestly just give them more
publicity
i i as a public public figure don't have
the same protections as a private person
and people can make what they want
of me and my story constantly without
having to consult me
so lots and lots of people are making
money
off of the worst experience of my life
and
i have no say in it
and then when you have a career that
isn't even you know when you just do a
podcast that's not about that you're
criticized for somehow
having a job yeah yeah but it's also but
i get criticized it's like that
it also now that you're like moving into
the things that you
um have earned and uh
deserve to be doing and should be doing
you're gonna
get shit forget italy you know what i'm
saying everyone that has a podcast and a
public figure gets shit so it's you're
also a lot of it
is not cumulative a lot of it is it's
just like
it's like in the roasts it's like when
we have nothing to get you on we're
gonna go for your looks
we have nothing to get you on it's like
the best thing that can happen to you at
a comedy central roast which is the
public flogging that we
sign up for yeah the shot and florida
festival
the um you know cutting just public
humiliation the roman coliseum like it's
kinky
if it's so kinky and you see us there
crying and sort of like trying to get
through it and i'm just trying to pay my
rent
and like that hurts is it like the purge
do you guys just do the purge
is this com comedian purge you get it
out
it's good for you it's really good for
you podcast
um no we do it
because we get paid oh yes you know what
that's great it's our job good on you
and but the friars club roasts were for
free
and truly this is how we
show love to each other when you grow up
in a home where people this is why i
loved roseanne
and why when i watched roseanne i was
like holy shit that's how my family
talks to each other
that's just everyone like some
everyone's scared barb
barb self-aware self-aware self-aware
like this is why i love
chris being like oh really because
everything's about you i
love that that's how we talk to each
other but he literally does that because
he knows that you like it
and he he's like so like but also you
know like
you're tr you're like it's a and maybe
it's a catharsis for you
because you know i wouldn't like that it
makes me think we're equals
and it makes me think you um
don't think i'm weak and fragile because
i'm sick of people thinking i'm fucking
fragile because i'm a woman it's enough
it's fucking enough do i mean it doesn't
it's not tracking for me
it's not true this narrative is not true
and it's not serving anyone so like when
you fucking come for me
oh and i wanted to talk to you about
this um uh
emily sent me uh the
there was this female
football player first female football
player okay
on uh women should be able to get
traumatic brain injuries too
yeah i mean which is like do i don't
think i mean don't get me started
i love i know exactly um so this woman
is named the the lost
vet the lost vet like
like sexy uh you know
um vet from the show or no this is weird
um sarah fuller hey girl first
woman to play for a power five college
football team last weekend is set to
continue her career with vanderbilt
the 21 year old took on kickoff duties
for the commodores last week after
several members of the team were ruled
out due to covet 19 protocols
okay and then so she's the kicker she's
a designated kicker okay
is that right sports is not where i
shine the comments
hope she gets plowed
huh publicity stunt
she's gonna get slaughtered on a fire
play
they couldn't have grabbed one from the
guy's team
is it bad that i want her to get rocked
i mean it's only fair
rocked meaning like tackles like what
does that mean someone better tackle the
fuck out of her make her realize it's 20
20.
i hope she gets plowed i mean that's all
i mean do they say that about
all the designated kickers because
that's not the job
i don't think pickers even get tackled
no they just go on the field
to kick the ball and then they leave the
field they're not built
to do what a line like and again like
that's also ridiculous to say because
like the person
i don't know much about football because
i don't play sports or i don't do
like i'm not a sports person but i know
that some people are
bigger because that's their job they're
supposed to like hold people back some
people
are smaller and they run fast and that's
their job and some people can kick a
ball
yeah and like it's not you know for a
lot of the things that happen in
football it
has to be a guy because like that you're
just the way that the game is built is
because that's how your body is built
but like the kicker is not net he
doesn't if you can kick the damn ball
like you can kick the damn ball um
so cucking i don't
i didn't fully understand because are
you talking about the kinky thing well
no people keep saying like he's a cuck
he's a cuck and
i and i sometimes pretend to know what
it is because i don't want to be wrong
embarrassed
and i'm like like it feels like a
political thing and like political just
it feels like sports to me and i just it
is sports i just yeah to me it feels
like 49ers versus
um i almost said the redskins the
dolphins
um i think a cuck is someone who allows
himself to be
dominated by a woman is that what that
means but there's an amazing
i think it was it derives from cuckold
right right which is
women getting fucked in the town
publicly
it cut so
so yeah when a woman is unfaithful to
her man like the husband is the one
who's the cuckold because
he is you know the woman's getting hers
behind the scenes when
she should be getting it from her
husband so it's humiliating sure she's
having multiple orgasms
it goes back to the epistemic gap
exactly
like any if you have a um an animal the
human
in which one of them knows that it's
their child and the other one just has
to hope
and the other one is bigger and stronger
they're gonna lock that shit down
and that's what you see all across human
cultures is the women are locked down in
various ways but i just it's the
i think we like to watch women be
humiliated
we have a way well it's a way to control
them but that's about humiliating the
man
that's about the you didn't lock your
woman down good enough yeah that's why
you're now a cock
yes you couldn't fucking you're a woman
well enough
you couldn't fuck your your dick's not
big well i think it's more so the shame
that men put on other men because how
are you going to protect your lineage
if you don't have control of that or
like people who
um who say rude things to me on
instagram like oh i bet you
are pegging your cuck husband so like in
our relationship the cuck is supposed to
is the one who takes on the
feminine submissive yeah that means
you're fucking the butt with the yeah
doesn't mean this whole thing is cuckold
the word the etymology comes from that
yeah the modern cuck is more like
a beta chump yeah right you're not an
alpha it's kind of what it's synonymous
with
yeah is it a chad is a chad supposed to
be the opposite of a cuck what is it
what's the opposite of a cook an alpha
whatever
what's a chat is that a thing i don't
know what a chat is is that like
don't incels describe chad's as the one
who's actually having sex
i don't know i don't know you guys don't
know anything about anything let's be
honest
i really don't let's be honest i'm
shocked
yeah so there's uh cuck as you might
expect comes from the word cuckold an
insulting word for a man whose wife is
cheating on him the oxford
english dictionary places its first
attested use in the mid-13th century
middle english poem okay i don't do
poems and the idea is that like if a
woman can get away with
cuckholding her husband it's because
he's a submissive and hasn't asserted
dominance
over his woman which is why like back in
the day they were like oh your way of
informing your wife that you love her is
beating her
because you care enough about her to
assert your dominance over her
but also it's like it's not that if the
wife is cheating on the husband it's
like even if the wife is raped
yeah even if like you didn't buy her
husband no it's hard
you didn't lock her down you can lock
her down enough right you the the
husband becomes the cuckold
because he failed in some capacity right
to lock her down
yeah the idea that like you have to be
asserting dominance
constantly for any human relationship to
have meaning
is silly as soon as you like as soon as
you
like get to a place where you don't have
to be asserting dominance like
then you have this eureka moment but if
you live in a world where
everyone is asserting dominance like you
don't
you don't understand that there's
another way to be and so like i feel bad
for when
people read like especially guys say
stuff to me like that because i
like wow you have never had a fulfilling
relationship
such a bummer i feel i love that you are
in the place and i think chris like it's
it's there's no reason you should be
here because i
you know i do call you the tiger by her
side you know it's like
um that you have compassion for the
people that come for you and like you
know their motives and you know that
hurt people hurt people and you know
that they're using you as their
anesthesia
yeah i mean it's a drug dealer it's so
obvious to me
yeah is the thing but when did it become
obvious when um
it i mean if you knew this when you were
in jail like how did you
so it was because then they're different
yeah i was impressed
[Laughter]
you learned this like two hours holding
up a mirror and i don't like it
i really hate everyone you hate them
um what was i gonna say um
when did you when did you know that that
people that attacked you
were in pain um
because i saw their pain like i don't
know i just yeah
i hate the word empathic it's kind of
like gotten a little bit like
like it's the water bottle i just like i
i've never
like had the impulse to punch a wall
right like
i know people do that when they're mad
and they and i've seen people do that
when they're mad and i've just never had
that
impulse before and i see them and like i
feel like
someone's impulse to punch a wall is
their same impulse to punch a person
there's same impulse to hurt a person
and i'm like you are clearly feeling
something
that i just don't feel ancestral
like it's so much bigger than you it's
so much bigger than me first reaction
and that's my fear about the neural link
that rogan's always talking about in
elon musk and and we were talking about
this
the other day which is like my first and
second
thought is probably not great it's never
great
and it's so wonderful that you
acknowledge that because other people
so much identify with their thoughts
that they can't
bear the thought of thinking the wrong
thing feelings are not facts
that is the first thing even your own
thoughts are not facts
like you can be like you they're not you
like you're not defined by your thoughts
or any
and uh my favorite part of that history
is when men realized that women needed
sexual satisfaction so they were just
like oh we're just gonna diagnose
hysteria
and give them dildos and
that was like almost compassionate but
then they also like locked them into
mental institutions and like thank them
am i making that up there's you're not
making that up and i'm happy to cut it
they
um they got so scared asking that they
said in court that and they claimed in
court that
meredith was intimidated by my
vibrator she thought that like i was
just this like overly sexual person
and she was intimidated by me and
therefore we had a fight
over my uncouth over sexualized ways
was she english she was english which
was a gift that vibra was a gift from
her
sort of tongue-in-cheek spencer's like
yeah last minute gift
yeah like oh you know she was like until
you find your italian stallion yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like
dick straws about like i've never used a
bunch i've never used it
never i've literally never used to buy i
don't even know how they i
more chargers i more batteries to lose
like i just actually okay fun fact i had
never masturbated until prison
i can't believe you just said that
because i said
i can't believe you said that because
the other night i was like i just want
to know if she masturbated in prison
because i
i masturbated
[Laughter]
because at a certain point i was like oh
what did you think about it i'm never
leaving here
i better figure this out that's fucking
so she had to time it between garden
rotations
yep you know one thing rotated they
masturbated very far
they walked past and looking yeah so you
have to wait until everyone's sitting
staring at you yeah they open up the
window
jeffrey epstein kill himself um i don't
think that it would be
like if he is really under suicide watch
there is no way that he would have been
able to kill himself
i was on suicide watch and there's no
way in hell that i would have been able
to kill myself
did you think about it i definitely
thought about it
um but also like it was funny that um
i thought about all the ways to do it
too because it was i
the way that i decided that i would do
it if i did it was i would slit my
wrists in the shower
with with um a broken pen
this way yeah yeah how did you know to
go this way
i've seen movies
actually it's true i have not seen shots
but i've seen enough movies to know that
you're not supposed to go like this this
is you're getting attention
how much time do you have to masturbate
between guard switches
you have to get really fast i saw her
cut tomatoes this morning
yeah um it was a deal because like every
most of the people in the prison were
taking medication to just kind of get
were you on medication
i was not wow the reason i was not was
one because i've never taken my i've
been the kind of person who i break my
foot i never want to take medication
you're not about anything now
i'm never on anything because i'm on
anybody i don't take ibuprofen and it's
not because i'm like weird and like i
don't trust like i get
i get vaccines like i'm not like against
things i just have
really really high pain tolerance really
like it's
it's weird how high pain tolerance i
have and i
don't like being vulnerable when i'm
scared so what i
saw was i don't like being
vulnerable when i'm scared so if i'm
scared
i am want to be as alert as sure got it
copy
i i do i am hyper vigilant i want to be
i don't even know before prison yeah but
well no not before prison before prison
i was like
carefree carefree i didn't think
anything bad could happen nothing bad
had ever sisters you're
i'm the oldest oldest yep nothing bad
ever happened to me
nothing bad had ever happened to them
super easy life
in fact my first thoughts when i went
into prison was oh i've had such an easy
life and like
karma forgot about me and then like was
like oh my god we have to do something
bad to amanda
just do a lot of bad stuff
like i'm so excited for this to be the
best thing for you
yeah um it's continually like hindsight
right now
and what's like what's really sad is
like a part of me wonders if he would
love me
if i hadn't gone through everything um
but that's a weird question because it's
like well i did
and here i am and he met me after it
happened and that it is part of who i am
so the thing that that's messed up about
that thinking is not the like
like the time runs in one direction so
like that sort of counter factual
thinking i don't really believe in
right but the the part i'm worried about
is thinking like
well this happened to me it's not of me
um and so what you like is a thing about
me that
that i didn't create and i think that's
wrong
um because i think that the the
environment is the
cauldron um you know you're the raw
ingredient and like not everyone emerges
from that experience the same that's
true
and you emerged who you are because of
how you decided to react to all that
so there's a lot of choices you made
every single day
right so i think you do have ownership
of who you became
yeah you're slowly convincing me of that
and i love you for it
svu svu i haven't seen it
there was an svu episode i'm trying to
look it up where they said
lexi's sexy lexi or sexy electricity and
they did an episode based on you
so here's the thing i don't care if
people do episodes based on what happens
to me like that's fine like that that
makes sense
the question i have is if you are so
going to directly reference me
and you're going to make that parallel
are you going to reinforce a false
narrative about me
or an actual narrative about me so like
if the story that svu presents
is a girl who loves orgies and like
and having sex with her drug dealer and
her roommates ends up dead and who knows
what the fuck
happened by the way maybe that's true
i don't know but like if if the ending
is well maybe she didn't maybe she did
then you're just reinforcing this like
narrative that is perpetually keeping me
boxed in because people pretend that
they don't know what happened
people pretend that there isn't clear
unequivocal evidence that some
motherfucker killed raped and killed my
roommate and i had nothing to do with it
and they liked the idea of her sorry
um they didn't find semen they found his
dna in her vagina though
they didn't they didn't test for semen
they didn't test for some um
there was semen on the pillow that was
found underneath
her her hips and they didn't test it
they didn't test it because they didn't
care because they had me and i don't
produce
i don't produce semen yeah so what they
wanted
was and as a scenario where some sex
happened and
i was the only responsible for it so
semen is irrelevant
right so like here i am going okay
like sure tell my story a million
different ways all the way you want it
except like
stop reinforcing this narrative that we
don't fucking know what happened
because that is bullshit and so like i
don't know i haven't seen the svu
episode i love law and order i'll watch
that shit all day
if your go-to outfit in 2020 has become
sweatshirts or yoga pants you may be
feeling like you're in a style
rut let's stitch fix i need your help
uh if you're watching the podcast if
you're listening you're gonna have no
idea what i'm talking about but i'm
truly naked
yeah if you're adam and eve and you're
stuck in a garden with nothing to wear
stixxfix will help you right out
stitchfix offers clothing hand selected
by expert stylist
i need clothes literally i'm naked at
the moment
for your unique size style and budget
i'm literally naked if you're watching
the youtubes because i don't
i don't like shopping for clothes it
stresses me out
but also malls are close now aren't they
are there any left yeah there are malls
but who wants to go there when you have
stitch
fix stitch fix stitch fix take your
style quiz tell them what you like and
they will send you a stylus will send
you personalized items for your style
your fit your wear
men women children they got it all this
company when i was 16
and buying dresses at jessica mcclintock
for prom they were in hollywood
they were working stylists they were
helping other people not you
this is for everyone now stitch fix this
company
basically automatically delivers you
hot fashion based on what you like off
your quiz yeah
let's just take a quiz get a look get
started today at stitchfix.com
whitney you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
whitney for 25 percent off when you keep
everything in your fix
stitchfix.com whitney i think it's safe
to say that some people are having
psychological challenges
right now name them who ever read about
it
me okay fine with me um
uh i think it's safe to say that
everyone could use a little mental
health support at the moment and i'm not
just saying that because i'm sitting
here naked
in my house um hosting a podcast in
front of a bunch of makeup
um holding a nose warmer if you guys are
only listening on audio i really feel
bad for you because you're missing a lot
of these hot visuals
but no actually you won't need you won't
need as much help
so maybe better help this is about
better help because you haven't caught
on yet
better help is you know we've talked
about before licensed professional
therapists they'll match you to
someone who will help you write up all
over this world why aren't you guys
doing this
betterhelp.com it's on your time but
everyone knows about it at this point if
you've listened to the podcast i think
now it's not just
like reading this thing it's like you
deserve it it was the holidays i'm sure
you saw
you've had some fights with just go get
help you with some answers be better
there's some things you need to unpack
let's be honest from christmas
new year's yeah your luggage see why is
that you're depressed
you're depressed pack your luggage
betterhelp.com
whitney that's better help h-e-l-p and
join the over one million people
i know mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney i just um
googled you oh how'd that go
how did that go it's better than
googling me um
but no i want to go back to uh lady gaga
yes
so sweet lady you are such a like
fucking
i it's very rare that someone makes me
laugh i'm pretty numb
i know where everyone's going i don't
it's frustrating to have to be performed
around people for comedians you know
it's like chris rock or um because you
guys are masters of the craft so you
like to
really do the twist you have to like
twist it who was it was it
chris rocker seinfeld one of them said
like when comedians are at a
event and another comedian comes in a
room they're like ah comedian
and they can sit in the corner and just
not be funny
you know yeah like we could totally be
like dude what the fuck
and not perform take the mask off
and like you are
sharp as fuck cutting
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not that was not a joke
[Laughter]
your cooking show knives knives out with
amanda knox
i mean it's a tough one i can't even
compliment you without um
razor sharp sharp with amanda knox
do you should have come out with a knife
a set of knives with christie
and connie's collection that actually
happened like the
the second i was acquitted the there was
a
promotional thing with a magazine in
italy that had like the front page
me getting acquitted and a complimentary
knife set
people love putting knives in my hands
or photoshopping knives into my hands
you know
because you're even near me so either
you're being murdered by me or you're
murdering people
with whose trajectory like monica
lewinsky does
does she when people come up to her um
are they like navy can she wear navy can
she ever wear beret again
she calls herself beret model former
brave model on her
twitter love her for that yeah yeah
i don't know if i would ever do knife
modeling
i don't think i would ever do that so
lady gaga tweeted
lady gaga tweeted um fame is prison
and i happened to notice that just like
as i was
i was doom-scrolling as you do like over
breakfast you were just like
scrolling you followed lady gaga i
follow lady gaga
i don't think you did i think you saw it
through someone else at the time oh
maybe someone
who i follow retweeted it i don't know
hasn't seen legends of the fall i
haven't seen legend in the fall
um but i noticed that lady gaga tweeted
that and i was like you know it would be
funny
i hear you lady gaga but prison is
prison
and um and that wasn't meant to like
call her out it was literally just
supposed to be like yeah like hey look
what we're doing right now yeah exactly
and i what what made me sad about the
reaction was people were like yeah man
to
burn her burn her and i was like i'm not
a burner like
but that's what twitter is it's the mosh
pit you're jumping in a mosh pit
it's the roman coliseum like you go in
there to fight it's the same instinct as
when the quarantine first happened and
everyone's like it's like being in
prison and amanda's like
let's remember that like present is
prison and like quarantine can suck
at the same time like as this whole
quarantine is going on
i'm thinking about the fact that not
only are prisoners in prison
but now they cannot even see their
families and if that was happening to me
like i lived for my visitations for my
family and they never missed a
visitation
how often it was eight hours a month
any iteration of so it was um
basically like almost once a week so it
was once fly to italy they had to fly to
italy they lived in italy so everyone
lived in italy for like a month at a
time and they and they spent that entire
month in italy so they could see me in
perugia italy
so that they could see me for eight
hours over the years
for one hour at a time over the course
of a month no
um and yeah and and
the idea that like there are people who
are going through that process without
having that connection to the outside
world
that and who are trapped in a covid
petri dish they're you know
trapped in a couple of petri dishes
that's me with
horses and barns and dogs and anything
trapped trap trapped yeah
they're literally trapped we are forcing
them to
you know we're we're exposing them to
risks that is not a part of their
sentence
and is there any country that you're not
like where are you the least famous
um that is a weird google trends can
answer this
you know what google trends can answer
that googletrends.com
yeah um and then you just look up
probably trends.google or
google earth so i'm doing mine yeah see
where you're the most famous
where you're the most googled yeah yeah
i have a lot of um support in ireland as
it turns out
nice islands islands love you okay so
except for england knox i don't know
what i'm looking at
kidnapping you can oh these are related
topics you can sort by country
and you can sort by state and think okay
this is like i i think this is we have
the data this feels like that
i'm on the dark web and i'm i feel like
i'm trafficking something
apparently alaska is your number one
state alas
people in alaska love you then rhode
island massachusetts
oregon colorado california doesn't like
you
no because i'm like what the fuck i'm
like i'm like alt-right to them
right they say that people should be
able to make jokes right
i'm a pariah in california because i
think that
um people should be able to get employed
in the pandemic
yep and they should be able to feed
their kids yeah
it's a hot take that i think that
and you know what you're allowed to have
it and i'm allowed to be wrong
yes you are dude she's wrong when he was
wrong about that thing
cool that's okay help me be right
not all right like i just want to learn
okay so yeah it's like it's a little bit
sloppy to be using you to
why were you trending for weeks ago like
you're a little bit of like slow news
day let's like trudge up amanda knox
i agree which is like your husband's
name
i did not um part of that is because
i didn't change my name when i first
came home precisely because
i was like people invited me and asked
me if i was going to do that and i was
like
i literally did nothing wrong there's
nothing wrong with amanda knox
everyone else has the problem so i'm
just going to
be me and i'm not going to like it felt
like i was giving
up i was giving in to the people who
were saying that there was something
wrong with being me
um and so i was just like there's not i
am assertively
telling you that there's nothing wrong
and why haven't you
watched the flight attendant um because
i've been here hanging out with you
we've been staying up until midnight
chatting and do you like it when people
reference you and stuff
because it's the conceit is you're
innocent
i mean i i appreciate when people care
about what happened to me and so i'm i'm
constantly
like when kristen shaw made that joke
about me in 30 rock i was like oh my god
like i was on kristen shaw's radar and i
love her and she's great
and or when i watch tina fey's other
show um the unbreakable kimmy schmidt
like there was so many moments well that
must have been
i felt so seen i felt so so seen
yeah orange is the new black didn't go
so well orange is a new black i tried
i um almost got through one episode
without having a panic attack but it i i
couldn't
yeah i i ha there are things like
especially the prison experience which i
haven't talked a lot publicly about
because a lot of people don't really
care
like the thing that was the most like
impactful for everyone else like the
trial and
the truly the like least interesting
thing about you
well like like the the narrative is the
thing that everyone cares about the
narrative like affected me in the sense
that it like your
sister tattoos like i have so many
do you want to know what these tattoos
mean sure um
yeah so uh this one which where's the
camera that one um first of all both of
these tattoos are tattoos that i share
with chris
we have the same ones um this is my
skeptic's tattoo so it's
um it's the um what is the symbol the
the resistor symbol so the resistor is
doesn't allow all the electricity
in and out so i'm being aware of
what information is being put in and
what information i give out i'm just
being conscious of that because
i need to be skeptical and i need to be
thoughtful about the things that i'm
allowing to affect me and the things
that i'm
putting out into the world this
here is a number of symbols this one the
venn diagram
is find common ground so when i'm
talking to someone i need to find a
common ground
if they're making an argument i need to
give them the benefit of doubt and
understand the strongest version of
their argument even if they aren't
expressing it well
i need to i need to see all the you and
me all the time
i need to have compassion and i need to
be willing to change
yeah let me take off my horse bolero
yeah take it
off this one i love it so this one is
white i got white tattoos because i oh
pretty you know what the tattoo artist
like i wanted white tattoos and they
were like no
this one says i love you which is just
for like i love it how it looks like a
scar
basically scarification yeah and then i
have an anchor right here
that's upside down i just want to just i
love you i like you i think you can
ask someone three questions and fall in
love with them
like i think or find a way to love them
not like sexual like i want to fuck you
but you can
find a way to the common ground of your
concentric circle yeah
i mean i want to understand people and i
don't think you can understand people by
judging them
where do you go on vacation i love to go
hiking i love to be outdoors and i also
love art museums which is why
ideally i would go to japan yeah for
for our honeymoon eventually um because
it's great food great outdoors great
culture
and great art that would be my ideal
place to to go
dude italy i am so obsessed my
the most beautiful place in the world i
think is ravello italy
um i've never been it's of uh by one of
my dearest friends
lizzie kaplan got married there um
it's so phenomenal but i i am
oh my god i just got scared to talk
about my mafia
[Laughter]
i that was weird it's like that's i
don't give a fuck about scientology
i'll like fucking go off on scientology
but mafia i'm like
like is there a presence here no but i
mean in italy like just from what i
learned from the berlusconi podcast
um it all feels
very emotional to me and very irrational
to me
and not that america is that different
and i cannot fucking stand when people
from other countries come in and
criticize a country they're not from
like that always bums me out i'm always
just like okay go back then
if you hate america so much go back like
let
we got it piers we got it thank you like
i'm
i'm sure he's like i think he's kind of
perfect i think him and ann coulter are
kind of performance artisty
you know i don't even know like they
perform i don't think they really
believe what they believe
i i just sort of like be interesting
it's like how you lean into
um borean surf uh very
brilliant uh neuroscientist at
northwestern who interviewed me for the
female brain and we just
we've talked about you a lot oh um about
memory and this sort of uncomfortable
thing that memory is imperfect and
that's not something to talk about
during the believe women thing
and you're not really allowed to say
that right now
um as someone who but it is absolutely
yes and the story is as stories get
retold
they get punched up they get changed
they get exaggerated
you can be convinced that you have a
memory that you've never had
like they've done studies on this i've
told stories that aren't lying
and thought they happened to me yep but
you know so without getting specific um
because it's a case-by-case basis yeah
there are times where it's like i'll see
someone accuse
you know a man of rape or assault or
something i'm like i don't think that
happened but i think something happened
to you
but it wasn't that you know what i mean
and it's like because women carry around
this like
cumulative arsenal of
every guy that fucking put his finger up
your butt
in the bar and every guy that just kind
of grabbed your neck and kind of
got you know that just and then
when someone that is click-baity does
that it's like
boom people can also have incoherent
um beliefs that they deeply believe and
they can be hypocritical it doesn't mean
that they're that it's not
true like when you talk a lot of
people's beliefs and coulter or pierce
morgan or whatever like
when when we went back to italy pierce
morgan was mad that when
what year what year sir last year yeah
last year what part of italy
i went i went to milan and yeah i went
to modena
is where it was ultimately going to take
place but like it what's it
oh um the italy innocence project which
didn't exist when i was going through
everything
was holding its first ever big public
event
about wrongful convictions and they
invited me to be the speed
keynote speaker to talk about trial by
media they pay you
uh none but it was
you know for the innocence project yeah
it's for the innocence project
it was fourteen piers is mad that
amanda's in the spotlight and that
it's a you know wait for your flight um
they paid for part of the part of it
yeah but you know what they did
give me a personal security guard when i
was there that was italian
yes yeah but he was great really really
great guy
love you giulio but you know he'd been
begging amanda to come on his show
and then he's mad oh begging me yes
yeah and indeed when i called him out he
was like yeah because you know what i
would ask you and i was like yeah you
would
victim blame me and not listen to
anything i had to say because you're
actually not interested so basically
but it's it's like
it's like we were talking about before
with the guns it's like it's like the
hustle
you know it's like the huckster it's
like it's like
feeding my family feeding the family you
know lots of ways to feed your family
what are your motives what are your
fucking motives it's sort of like
you know we're all just trying to get
ours you know we're all just trying to
fucking
do it but it's like the good and evil
it's the goodwill and it's interesting
because i have this
um thought that right now with the
radical
transparency thing that's going on right
now which is like
what do you mean by radical transparency
like everything you've
ever done right right and will be held
again you are only as sick as the
secrets you keep bitch like there is
like
everyone is on notice at the damocles
sword has been hung
and the halloween costume that you wore
when you were 17 might lose you your job
that you deserve to have
yeah it's bullshit and it reminds me of
how people use that
against me in the courtroom 100 and it's
like oh you mean like oh
rafael's halloween costume from a few
years ago is being used was that a thing
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah i mean he had
a halloween costume where he was like
wrapped up as like
in blackface he was wrapped up as a like
in uh
he was like in a mummy costume and he
had like a meat cleaver i don't even
understand like
like they dug through their myspace
pages yeah and he found a picture of a
man
for ways to make a psycho holding uh you
know i was playing with like one of the
machine guns and it was just like
how old were you i was you know like
1920s
you also were the this is like almost
like the fir
you were like the martyr of
birth of social media right around the
same time yes kids got used to be able
to do this in private and it wasn't
documented
it was like the first like out of all
the people iphone had just been invented
twitter was was new out of all the
people in the world
to be kind of the one that got it
because we all did that shit
of course in front of mirrors and we
sang in the shower yeah we did all the
shit and the
um i mean there's some printed pho like
there was a printed photo
um that me and my friends uh i won't
name because i won't drag them into it
where i was dressed as a geisha because
i
ordered this beautiful uh i love kimono
so much yeah
i ordered this beautiful kimono i found
it no i found a flea market
and um i put the um i took baby powder
and i mixed it with water and did the
whole thing
the traditional thing i loved um and
there's a printed photo of it
floating around and i remember and i
think about it like a couple times a
week i'm like
okay that's going to get you yeah one
day maybe
maybe yeah you know so we're all in this
sort of like when am i gonna
i just find it fascinating how like we
have there are so many reasons
for you to like have problems with
people and yet we're finding
reasons to have problems with people
that are not real reasons are you into
terror management theory at all
uh explain or it's i can't eloquently
but essentially we're the only species
that knows we're gonna die
so we have to sort of like you know
engage in all this rigmarole trophies
and teams and tribes and to um
uh symbols and uh shields with
what are the scottish emblems that
emblazoned on a
shield like a nittany lion
like crest thank you um uh
to have posterity to feel uh some level
of immortality because
certainly we'll all imminently die right
and we're also like entering into a sort
of regression to
a place where we need instead of like
being this sort of enlightened
world where everyone finds their own
meaning and is the the author of their
own meaning
we are instead regressing back to a
world where we want to be told
what everything means and who we are so
that we can belong
and we all just want to be love i mean
it's just we just want to be loved
and loved seeing heard and loved seeing
heard and loved and the easiest way to
do that is
join other people in judging someone
who's an outsider and also it's it's
this shame we carry around of like
forgive yourself you know it's like
everyone that
thought you did this and got off on it
and
thought it was titillating and
skittilating
scantilating scallops scandillating
that's great
ventilating scintillating scintillating
i have a little speech impediment that
doesn't allow me to do that um
and so like i say don't ride elephants
at the end of every episode
um because i rode elephants in thailand
and i didn't know yep and i had a framed
photo of me on an elephant and then
i am like into getting elephants out of
circuses and moving those
elephants out and then i look through a
picture and i'm like there's i see the
chains on the feet and i'm like oh my
god
i did that yeah yeah and there's gonna
be
and they're gonna be things 20 years
from now i've done that
didn't know i've done that
bitch i just feel like i made a best
friend is it is amanda knox my new best
friend
um i wasn't listening i was playing best
fiends i don't know if you guys are
friends or not but i
have to ask i just made a best friend
amanda knox has done two episodes of
we had a two-parter and i leveled up
some tiny bugs
so you're jealous of me and amanda
knox's best friendship so you're playing
best
best fiends in the corner like a brat
all my friends and me are on best fiends
[Music]
best fiends is now that i have her best
friend
name amanda i have someone to play with
she'll play best fiends i bet she would
play with me
she's my best fiend amanda knox is my
best friend i love best fiends
so where do you play best fiends and
please don't i play it on my phone
when you're played online when you're
getting my prozac at the rite aid
no um i play it i'll tell you when i
play it i play it because
it's it's that game remind everyone it's
a game on
in the app store yeah it's an online
like role play game on your phone where
you get to play as these different kinds
of bugs and you fight slugs
and you level up your bugs and they
change looks it's very
it's like role play and you don't have
to have sex at the end it's the best
different role play yeah i play mine
though i like to when i pop in my my
nuggets in my toaster up and i like to
play it while they
while they're toasting so you play best
fiends while you're making nuggets
yeah of course i'm so into video games
right now like
best fiends otherwise i'm just gonna be
scrolling instagram i'm gonna be like
looking at exes
looking at their new girlfriends like
it's just so unhealthy where my brain
goes yeah pretend your ex is a slug
fight em so i go to best fiends instead
taking a contrary action listen it's a
five star rated puzzle game it has over
a hundred million downloads it's like
it's the game binge worthy mobile puzzle
game
free to download um download best fiends
free today
on the app bull app store
you say it download best fiends free
today on the apple apps or google play
that's friends without the r best
fiends f-i-e-n-d-s are you my best
friend or my best fiend
um amanda is my best fiend the best time
of your life
listen multivitamins we're all taking
them no
benton we're not taking them what a
segway
you're still naked and we're we've been
naked for four or four
of these we talk about ritual vitamins
on the show quite a bit
yeah it's our ritual yeah it's our
ritual to talk about the ritual on the
show
i always screw up this ad read so i'm
gonna let benton take this one from here
ritual it's not your typical
multivitamin it's clean
vegan friendly formula with key
ingredients that's been on it since
before i had a podcast just saying
she has it forms and it's key nutrients
and forms your body can actually use
ritual is a multivitamin reimagined it's
formulated with key
nutrients including vitamin d3 to help
fill gaps in the diet
vitamin d3 which helps your immune
system their fresh tasting delay release
capsules are designed to dissolve later
men women and teens there's vitamins for
them that are now available they're
scientifically developed to help support
different stages all of your life
whether you're a man woman or a child
every life station will support
you deserve to know what's in
multivitamin that's why ritual is
offering our listeners 10 percent off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com whitney to start your ritual
today
so who's your dream guest on your
podcast oh
um which is
can i tell you an
audio a velveteen audio experience i
mean it is
so well mixed it is so sm
it's like a jack it's like jazz it's
just like the pacing's perfect
we really work hard to make it i'm a
fucking nightmare i am
so like use were we watching something
adr did you watch me yell adr at some at
movies
no when i watch movies i'm like adr adr
looping
like you know emily it's the worst
i have no notes on your podcast amazing
i can be a listener
wow well i really and i have misophonia
which is like the
you're the i hear things really loudly
that's amazing i
i really appreciate that because we've
worked really hard you don't say like a
lot which i'm working on
you're not like like like like
well being forced to like first of all
yeah right being forced to first of all
learn another language and then have to
perform for your life
makes you very self-aware perform for
your life say that again a different way
perform for my freedom so here i am i
have one chance to
make my case in front of a court i'm not
allowed to speak the vast majority of
the time that i'm on trial
i'm not allowed to even defend myself
the one chance that i do is the one
chance that i have
and that ultimately is interestingly the
thing that is going to
be the biggest outcome because people
don't judge based on the evidence they
judge based on how they feel about you
and then yeah
yeah yeah and your reaction yep so
did you speak i remember i remember
having to stop i hit the space bar when
you um
were it they said you're innocent and
you like kind of collapsed and cried
like i had kind of hit the space bar did
you ever speak to them
yes i right before they um
went to go do a verdict like when
everyone was doing closing arguments
i had a opportunity to stand up and
speak in italian in italian amanda knox
is getting married in 40 days but she's
still
rocking her old prison uniform
cnn do better yeah if that's on
cnn whoa that is like low hanging
and also like again i'm doing a lot of
things
why are we looking why are we making
fake
headlines from knox that's like a
fucking if
i'm working in a news station i'm like
nexium knox fuck yeah
that's sexy boom boom boom boom foxy
noxy nexium
yeah for the record i know nothing about
that case
and the only thing i know anything about
is conversations about prosecutorial
integrity which is how i was introduced
into this whole thing in the first place
wow so i have no opinion on that case
because i haven't
been funny you're not going to make
crass jokes and i'm not such a fucking
bummer because you're so
fucking no well thanks i mean i can do
it around you
and then hopefully and it annoys me
because i'm like fuck
it's funny fuck it annoys comedians
does it yeah what other people are funny
it annoys us
i should have thought of that oh i see
fucker like that's what we do yeah
but you think what that would feel like
you will make me laugh like you will
make me like laugh laugh like you're
uh you're very surprising and i think it
would be this way even if i
didn't have a pre you in my hippocampus
like really
amanda knox i wonder like my impression
is that people tend to have
an already preconceived notion of me
that is very easy for me to break
because
i'm very much not what people imagine
yeah
you're not just like jerking them off
the second you meet them yeah
you're not just masturbating i don't
walk in around like this
he's also not enigmatic you know like
that's a that's a false yes
by the media like the idea that i'm like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like you're
just this sign you're in this section
a while ago what was it was that paid it
was
okay um and then i heard i was
overhearing people in the
fan line talking to you and i i
overheard these two girls walking away
from the talk going
she wasn't that weird yeah they're like
i'm supposed to be having like wrong
reactions to everything in the world
because everyone's like oh she's must be
people have been told me oh you must be
histrionic oh you must be like you just
might be on the autism spectrum and i'm
like good job
diagnosing me from afar what's your
dream next 10 years
my dream next 10 years is that chris and
i
um start a family and
with you clearly um we're the best
threesome ever
and um we have a successful show yeah
podcast well podcast or we're developing
a number of shows including a comedy one
about pariahs
so about what it's like to be a
public-facing woman
particularly when we you know how we
talked about like there's
being famous by the way don't even get
me fucking started on all the shows
that say uh a whitney they want a
whitney cummings type and don't want me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's cute well it means they know you
then i'm like
people know me
people know me yeah do they
[Laughter]
i have no idea how famous that you and i
walking into but we
a little like um thing that's just
called do you know have you heard of me
do you know me like i just want to go up
to people like have you ever heard i
just need to understand where i stand
sure i don't care what the answer is i'm
just genuinely curious
but if we go out to coffee together and
like
yeah and then see what happens i think
it would depend on where we go but
i think you would get it let's fly that
airline together oh my god
right what what name do they yell yeah
i i would be holding your purse in the
background
okay so making the show you want a
scripted show or you want it loosely
scripted improvised
i would love a scripted show because
chris and i are writers and
i would love a comedy show because i
am first of all i love comedy like
i at the end of a long day of dealing
with really really serious shit
which we do kind of like i just would
like you to stop talking about blood
well yeah and like or like there's just
like a million ways that people can be
victimized and i empathize with that
i love goofy shit like i know i know
weird al songs by heart
you're a goofy so i love goofy shit and
like this is my
my catharsis at the end of the day is
cooking dinner while listening to
weirdos
you're like a nerdy yeah and then watch
doctor who
yeah no you're not a doctor food fan i
don't
i don't know whoville
don't worry about it i don't really know
what that i look like a whoville yeah
but very different than whoville yeah
yeah it's just sci-fi it's just like
goofy
silly are you a cosplay oh my lord
so okay so you didn't invite me to bring
costumes over
dungeons and dragons we play dungeons
and dragons my
current character is named earrings
larping we've um my first ever so
our like this is how we knew we were in
love and whatever like
his first um birthday that i was a part
of
i organized with his brother who is a
professional
knight who jousts and everything we
orchestrated
a whole day of larping
where he was a futuristic like sci-fi
agent i woke up in the morning tell it
from your perspective and i
stumbled to the bathroom and there's
this there's this weird outfit there
it's like red leather coat and a pair of
like weird futuristic sunglasses
and she's gone and i'm like where did it
go what store
goodwill and then i take a shower and
then
as the mirror fogs up i see that someone
has written on the mirror
see you next time coco and i'm like what
is this and then i get a phone call from
like an altered voice that's like
meet in the cafe you know it's there's
this whole like adventure planned out
that we organized all of us we wrote a
story who's the line producer
his production we wrote a whole story we
got all
all of the friends in on it everyone was
a character we
organized the whole neighborhood we set
up like things for him to like find
throughout the neighborhood because he
had like a secret mission
we like it was a whole day worth of like
everything's ever not secret
i guess not right yeah i'm just trying
to under i'm gonna
get in your larp yeah no but like it was
so great and like his like his
introduction to me was like i had
like the crazy mask on and he had to
like battle me in a battle of wits of
like
laser chess and then once he did like
like it was
all everyone had a character and um
it was super fun so what's your
franchise
what's our franchise harry potter yeah
oh
yes my franchise that like got me
through a lot actually like harry potter
really helped me out when i was in
prison because i've read the book so
many times that
reading them in italian helped me learn
italian whoa
yep and you have like tampons and stuff
no
you we had pads um so
we had these giant thick ass pads
and we've had to like you know ration
them and everything like it was a
thing um and a lot of people are
mentally ill in prison and some of them
would like ration their used one sure so
it's like um
it's green yeah it's it's like yeah
prison is
i don't recommend that we're out i don't
recommend it
there's a um comedian named stephanie
escaheda
who i came up with and uh she tweeted
one time she um went to jail like for a
night for something and she just tweeted
this is like back in the day like my
space days and she just tweeted prison
as a no joke
it was so funny like at the time um it's
like you're in jail not prison
um and then okay so you're harry potter
uh you harry potter fan okay yes
i'm a hufflepuff and then so lord of the
rings are we doing that
love lord of the rings um didn't grow up
reading the books as much as harry
potter
he did um and
what's the point of lord of the rings
what's the point of the odyssey yes
good question i fuck with the odyssey
yeah that's why you should fuck with
lord of the rings but i was i was
so young when i read it it made me feel
smart um
that's also a good reason joseph
campbell
is the only way that i could like deal
with scary things i could read about
scary things like arl steins scary
things i couldn't watch are you afraid
of the dark
are you afraid of the darkness you
remember
oh my god like i would try to watch
side tails from the dark side no
is this another wave come through
tales from the dark side it was like
these little horror like
featurettes they were like 12 minutes or
something
and there was one that was a blob that
was in the middle of a lake
and these like hot girls and guys that
deserve to die because they fucked and
were sexual
right um went to the lake to fucking
drink
and this blob just like ate them and
there was one where the cat
kept chasing the guy and the cat i think
this is my thing with cat
problem with cats oh and a cat didn't
know you had a problem with cats
it's like i have like a little bit of
like a fear of that it's going to go in
your mouth it and he it goes in his
mouth and kills him i'll send it to you
oh you guys have heard of this okay i
have not seen i mean old yeller wasn't
great
either so this aired from 83 to 88.
i was born in 87. but did they rerun it
i'm sure that it was on reruns yeah yeah
i'm sure it was one of my runs
yeah like we do just train
our children to want
to be tension and fear i mean it's the
grimm's fairy tales fucking scary as
fuck we love it
yeah and they're morality tales and then
yours is fantasy too i mean it's like
all crime is fam it's like it doesn't
matter if it's true or not i just
said it's tales from the crip tales from
the dark side it's a puzzle
yep i love it and also it's like a
statement about human nature like i
think the
the saddest thing about the statement of
human nature that people tried to push
onto the story of my roommate being
murdered and me being accused was that
there was some problem between me and
this other woman
that like all of this pain and death and
destruction
was the result of women hating other
women and that was so
not true that's it and also it's
we are um people stay in power by
separating uh uh uh making it impossible
for collusion to happen
so and um everyone knows that my
ancestry is west virginia
and all of the slaves that came in to
work in the coal mines
from italy from ireland scotch irish
scotland
um from africa they kept them separate
so they could not collude
you know that was like the union's i'm
sorry the way of avoiding them
unionizing
right rising up that is how that is how
they keep us
and this business has done it every
sort of i think business does it in some
way is just
keep the women and this is what me too
happened everyone's like
i think it was annie letterman who's a
comedian uh dear friend who was like
boys will be
boys but girls will be girls so for your
wedding you made a
spaceship so for our wedding um the
wedding theme was
time travel and of course if you're
going is that a thing
no string theory no no it was just
general
real life i mean are we oh is time
travel possible i mean
sorry that was dumb that was dumb i'm
dumb
says brodie stevens if you don't get me
you're
dumb brody stevens 101 comedian i will
introduce you to him cool
killed himself oh broke my heart
he won't introduce me to him at all
and so um string theory
um for like masturbatory what do we do
yeah yeah it didn't need to like make
sense what needed to happen was
we needed to have accidentally destroyed
the time stream continuum yeah
and all of our family members and
friends
needed to come together to be a part of
this ceremony to restitch space and time
so that was like the they were shattered
throughout space and time
and that's why you arrive at the wedding
from different time periods yes
um and they so they were solve a bunch
of puzzles i had a friend who showed up
as a dinosaur
so like their people weren't even human
anymore like this was
um so the the meteorite they died oh yes
yes
yes the ice age following the meteor yes
blocking out the sun
and that's posed by having a meteor hit
your
crash land in the backyard yep i was
sewing a wizard cloak one evening
and out of nowhere this like
the sound of what's what i thought was
like
north korea bombing us like came out on
our loudspeakers like just
and he's like oh my god i think
something landed in the backyard so we
went out there
and et music starts playing which is
where all these people
you got that right tmz saw the proposal
video and assumed that it was
et related all the e.t that had to do
with it was
that it was the music at the end of the
et movie that was
the music playing as i was discovering
this meteorite
and inside this meteorite was a
broken labradorite plaque
from the encyclopedia galactica many
many many many thousands of years in the
future that described our future
together
and we took this idea of there's
something happened in the future
that launched something from the future
to the past and
it broke the time stream continuum we
took that idea
and we built an escape room wedding
where all of our guests had to arrive
in costume from different time periods
they chose
and we had a ceremony
where we didn't walk down the aisle we
had to be re-materialized
had to make it about me how to make a me
it wasn't about me
we we had to re-materialize
in these specially constructed canisters
that were constructed in the future to
re-materialize
lost time stream continuum
space objects which was us so our family
members had to like input their dna
a future tech support person from the
encyclopedia galactica had to
orchestrate the wedding he was our
efficient there was
laser lightsaber battles there was
like it was a whole thing and we had
puzzles that
we made ourselves so we had a year
making puzzles we spent a year
making puzzles like escape room puzzles
escape room puzzles for every single
table at the wedding everyone had to
solve their puzzles in order for chris
and i to
successfully be married and
re-materialized
so that was the idea of the wedding and
all of our friends and family say it was
the last fun thing
because then the pandemic happened we
were so fortunate
that it was february 29th february 29th
right oh is that leap year leap day larp
day
larp day leap day it was the day we took
the leap a better day for time travel
wedding the day that only exists every
four years
yeah names are incredibly important you
know that i was almost named amanda
hi they named me first oh that's so
weird that i just remembered that hey i
remember that's when i'm here a couple
years
i asked my i asked my mom i think
everyone's struggling
with their relationship with their
mother ask your mom
questions about herself she knows
more than you even if she's hurts your
feelings even if she's a nightmare even
if she's a mess
she's doing the best she can with the
tools she has forgive her and ask her
questions about her wedding
how did he do it were you scared and i
asked my i finally
figured that fucking out georgia said to
me she was just like
well what about your mom like how would
she know
what what tools does she have in her
toolbox and i was like
like she's you what if you had a kid
right now how would you
d you'd be a mess too and um
i asked her like about her wedding and
stuff
and uh were you in the womb at the
wedding
in the womb i was in my mom's womb at
the wedding
i was like at the wedding wow let's talk
about epigenetic imprinting at some
point but
i want to know more what what's what did
you learn from your mom
my mom was stood up at the altar
canceled the wedding the day before
two rings uh two engagement rings
that i am now making into a necklace
like things that you're just like i
didn't
how would i know i i all i was only
thinking about myself
all i was thinking about is that you're
not good and a good enough mom
mm-hmm and i oh
oh um she
i used to and everyone's always like why
do you have all these like christmas
decorations and parties everywhere and
this and the pomp and the circumstance
and the gifts and the yeah
my mom was in public relations for
uh bloomingdale's neiman marcus and i so
i grew up in malls
i grew up in shopping malls and shopping
malls are all about fucking decorating
for the holidays and i
mariah carey
[Laughter]
how are they able to afford it every day
at 5 00 pm no it's it's for them
they get it free i mean it's promotion
uh it's like oh the the i'm obsessed
with
uh casinos and mall psychology the
smells
the lack of clocks the music
the air con you know they do yeah they
both they both give me incredible
anxiety because i feel
trapped i know that they're trying to
trap you
yeah casino's no good no i've been to a
casino senator you coming like haunted
houses
no no oh
very bad i again i feel very trapped and
i don't
like feeling trapped i i don't do well
in closed space it's interesting because
i have
that not because um because of the
ancestral
uh coal mining stuff a lot of people um
that were in coal mines because you have
to go like truly a mile down in an
elevator
totally in the coal mine explosions i
mean horses were down there
jesus i didn't know they would fit i
mean i guess they make
their big enough holes horses would go
down die
inhaling the which is i have a whole
thing with the lungs so it's like i i
think a family constellation is in your
future
i know it sounds are you saying that i
just look like i'm about
like bursting to like bursting with like
family consolation is like the ancestral
trauma you carry
oh some of it is hooey fooey buoy fine
some of it is makes total sense uh
have i fully told the horse carriage
story dave
i don't know i don't think so come on
you've talked about them be serious
you oh you just did with elsa
i think that was the first time you've
ever about saving the the course
carriages
yeah i mean it's like
when like what is your lot like what is
the unfinished business
you know of your ancestry and we look at
herding dogs and
last night we were watching a video
about the um sheep and the uh
all i was looking at was the herding
dogs i was like
because herding dogs that's the only way
they can experience the world and i
always discourage people from buying
these
aussie shepherds australian shepherd
birds because they
if they don't have a flock they're like
a piece of them
it's stressful for them where's the
flock
right and then they try to like herd
humans and then they get into trouble
because they're like nipping at humans
if your dog is barking you gotta let
them bark dude that's just in there
they're doing their job you know never
declaw a cat for like
people like huskies like oh so much work
it's like why did you get a husky like
they have it in there
they get dopamine from why doesn't it
just exist
the way i want it to exist yeah why
can't you already be a trained dog why
aren't you my toy
be my toy human woman animal
yeah no i get really over time
[Laughter]
no it makes me upset like i genuinely
feel like when people
i get i i feel bad when again like i'm
drawn to the at the thing that has the
least agency in the room
and when i see people who treat animals
like toys i go offline
like they're they have feelings like
they are
eclectic it's frustrating i get
i go i mean you i mean i
drove through a fire to try to get a
giraffe i mean i'm like i go
nuclear because i was in a fire as a kid
it's like we
owe it to ourselves and everyone around
us to figure out what the
fuck we come from you know what i mean
in what we're carrying the guilt we're
carrying the shame we're carrying the
unfinished business like that's your
job to figure out it's not my problem
this isn't mine this is your back it's
in your backpack take the shit out of
your backpack
and get rid of it so the family
constellation which is
i'm sure we talked about this a little
bit with kesha
like i'm sure it's part foue but who
gives a
fuck you know i've not heard about this
placebo effect i'm
is in effect right it's maybe can
someone look up
what the because i always say like 60
um and like who decides these things as
my dad would say
like what pew rece i feel like pew is
the only one i respect
for some reason why is that been around
for a long time
pew and berg they've consistently done
what feel like studies that feel that
feels
facts you know what i mean does it feel
true
yeah um so i'll say it
in short because i think next time maybe
we do a family constellation
um if nothing we'll get a joke out of it
oh yeah i'm german let's go let's go
there
have you not done your ancestry or any
of your lineage um
i know my great-grandfather was in the
nazi army
so like i know that like that's a thing
like i've seen pictures of him in
uniform like that's a thing
it makes me so sad i mean and at the
same time like here's my
my oma who was in austria
while this is going on her mom died
because a bomb fell on her and she was
starving to death and like
all of that is like real and
um it's interesting how there's like
this generational gap
of wanting to talk about it like our
generation
wants to talk about it but the
generation my almost generation or even
my mom's generation
doesn't want to talk about it they want
to move on and they don't want us to be
carrying
their burden but they don't realize that
we are
carrying it anyway so
you might as well talk about it she's as
fuck
so i when i go to new york you've seen
me
were you with me emily when i was um at
i think it was like fallon
or letterman or something and
whenever i new york is hard for me
because the horse carriages
i just can't do it i i have ridden in a
horse carriage before mm-hmm
that's i don't know better have i i
think in charleston
i've done it like multiple times because
i'm like horses i am obsessed with
um uh lex friedman if i can ever get him
to uh have the time for me
in every way
tesla programs uh what what's his job
ai scientist no doubt mit professor
the that's good sexiest russian
um and uh to make robot horses
so that we can have more surges so much
cooler
and by the way that's where fucking asia
and then people will ask if they can
touch it
robot wreck robot restaurant which i
want to show you
cool um so robot fucking horses great do
it
man um which is a whole other
conversation about robot
brothels and women and does it
exacerbate or does it
is it cathartic um and so i would cry
every time i saw horse hair just like i
would
like fly forward in a taxi cab and
i had to cancel letterman when i was not
famous
like when i was not um
i should be so lucky i would be like
i can't i can't i was in a it was like a
muscular
you know the body that heals itself is
that the trauma of release book
um and i just had so much shit with
with seeing horses pull carriages and it
was just like so
upsetting and so upsetting and then i um
you know was just like i'm just i'm
emotional i'm crazy i'm a woman
like i'm on my period all right maybe
i'm just on my p i have ibs like it's
probably just like i'm just
jealous of someone um i'm sensitive
and then my dad died and i
said to my
uncle like a couple months later we were
talking and i was just like making
conversation after i had done the family
constellation i'd done a family
constellation where this
woman came over i'll give you her
information she should come on with you
next time and she
makes you stand on a piece of paper like
with your ancestors names on it and it
was just like
what am i doing this is so fucking l.a
this is ridiculous
are we gonna get charcoal toothpaste
next i mean
it sounds like that what is the game
where you put your hands on the circles
it's like trauma twister which was like
the most sexual experience of my
childhood again
of course like tea bags little eyeballs
yes like just yes under the guise of a
math game
yeah that's cute um like dots dots like
are we
fucking why humping on this
um and uh and then
i don't i just don't know a lot like i
just no one talked about it
and i was like and she was like your
great great grandfather
um did something unforgivable
and i was like well yeah of course they
cheat all men cheat
uh dinosaurs oh tracks alcoholic
and then your mom
uh grand gregor or mother used
the tactic of withholding love to punish
i do that
what is it is this person just saying
this stuff out of the blue like
she's sitting on the couch i filled out
a questionnaire this is based on things
you've written down
or is she just bullshitting you i wrote
i answered a bunch of questions i'll
have to find them is there documentation
that
you know person used love to with
withholding love et cetera no it's by
the way
so it's not it could also be a struggle
yeah oh she's doing like
i read a taurus that works too pisces
that works too
they all work if i want them to work i
can like
so it's basically like whatever pings
you as true
is true i'm like i'm fucking in i want
to heal
i want a new story i want a new story
i'm sick of my story my story is not
working
like just let's rewrite it refresh
update the software like i'm just
in pay you by check fuck it i'll drive
to
a weird hotel in venice and pay you by
bitcoin
don't pay
little bag of rocks sure like i was just
like anything to stop
crying in my car um and
then she was like on your uh your
yeah your dad's greater grandfather did
something unforgivable and you're
carrying his guilt and it's an
unfinished
it's unfinished business you're carrying
his unfinished business do you feel like
you needed a reason why though
like the thing that i've found from
meditating is that
the reason why we feel or think
anything doesn't have to make sense it
can just
be something that appears to you yeah
and
i don't need a reason to know
like i don't need to know why i'm
feeling bad to know that i need to
do something about it like i know that i
know you need to take an action
you need you don't need to take you're
saying you don't need to take an action
well i don't need to like
seek out my ancestors to understand
that sometimes i feel shitty about
myself
or about the world like i i just sort of
allow i need proof my brain needs proof
i need proof you need reasons true
data i need data as long it can be fake
i'm happy to change my mind i'm happy to
be wrong but terror management
warm with the core 101. like i need
something i need a wall to make my head
on
and so you need a scapegoat
no you're the monster
180. um
and then yeah no i i didn't follow you
as
because i was in my own shit at the time
um of course
and then as we all are i think some
people followed me just because they
were in their own shit
and i was a good distraction yeah so
that's fine like i get it such a good
punching bag
she's got a very punchable face i
can't look and so um to make a long
story
fucking so long that i think the cards
are running out
with cameras dave um
getting there getting there let me just
and wrap this up
um is that and then did something and
i'm talking to my uncle mark who is
amazing
just amazing and um
i'm like hey i did this family
consolation thing i'm a dumb lib tard
from
l.a and i did family constellation and
i'm like ah my life is so hard
a white woman from l.a and my life is
hard
um and what's up with my great great
grandfather
and he was like um oh yeah he died of
cirrhosis
tracks got it he um he
worked in uh west virginia made
a part that adhered
horse carriages together
like he's the guy that figured out how
to make the axel stick together
i was like he manufactured the manacles
manacles i don't know what it means
what manacles what's a miracle you know
that
yeah yes don't flirt
and then you know about the sword of
damocles but you don't
have animals i went to monocle
which i've um and uh and i was like well
everyone
probably that was everyone's business
back then do you know what i mean like
everyone worked in horse care
everyone you know what i'm saying so
it's like i'm always like challenge
challenge challenge
and then he was like no no like he was
the guy that like
figured out how to get the wheels to
stop going like
out you know what though he didn't
invent the uh
the a-bomb he did not
it's pretty cool but he didn't do that
it's pretty cool he wasn't opening yeah
was that right feel better i actually
it's a team effort it's team effort so
it's like it's like it's like let's be
let's go on this hike and go on all
these wrong trails wrong
wrong run where we're wrong and then get
this amazing sunset at the end
you know it's you know what's true and
this is what
all of our ancestors have done something
unspeakable
all of that all of them and they had to
to survive none of us
is is untouched by somebody doing
something fucked up because that's human
are we used to watch
tigers tear apart human beings in a ring
sam harris we're no different than those
people
we just do it now on twitter yep egging
people's houses brains are no different
our brains are you know modern humans
have been around they have not covered
thousands it's astonishing that we still
don't do that uh if you want um
for christmas gifts sapiens
oh yeah yeah we read um which we read
which was the one that we read by yuval
harari
sapien we already read it and then homo
and hamadeos we already read humayun i
was so scared of his pronouncing
um have you read the righteous mind by
jonathan hate nope
really really michael mallison that's a
probably the worst idea you've heard in
a while best book
we read that right the new right the
righteous mind the righteous
mind it kind of gets into why
politics and everything everything is
sports teams
um and also like the core i'll get into
i would love to read that hammer that
but like moral intuitions where they
come from like i love talking to people
about
just want to feel safe and protected and
loved at all times yes but all of us
feel it in a different way
which is interesting fuck you man you
win
who won this one who won this podcast
emily there you see but here's the thing
we don't have some one of us doesn't
have to be pegging the other
we can be you know what i mean are there
even nerve cells in the butthole
i feel it when it happens
i definitely feel that so there's gotta
be some i think it's the first time i've
ever seen dave
with his hands on the back of his head
and just go i'm a father
don't write elephants labyrinth
reference plural spotify
stitcher everything wherever you get it
thank you follow amanda
i do have some notes on your social
media because please it's very
um trepidatious as it as of course it is
yes i am very cautious and i would love
to be less he's trying to convince me to
be less cautious you want me to put that
carol baskin dance on
i want us to do a little series of all
the things you recorded and never posted
diy okay because i have problems with
tiger king that are
so far beyond the carol baskin part of
it the part for me that like hurt the
most
was when the mama tiger gave birth and
then they immediately
no they always do for the cub heading
always they have to they kill them right
away
come petting always always always always
always if anyone is touching a lie
an apex predator lion tiger or bear it
is always abuse always always always if
you see it on the morning news
if you see it on the fucking side
in you know the ozarks if you see a
human being getting anywhere near
touching a tiger that means the mom was
killed immediately black
tiger white jaguar black tiger i don't
give a fuck
these people are nuts doc antle malibu
wines fire i don't give a fuck
dude it's all abuse
and it also suppresses um their immune
system
because they uh can't get the breast
milk yeah they're they're awake in their
mouth
and they die and they are also on drugs
so anytime you're taking a picture with
a lion in thailand or a tiger in
thailand they're always drugged and
white tigers are
always in bread uh cross-eyed
and can't hear or see and it's all
um father's fucking daughters and
brothers and shit
i know it's it's i'm in too deep turns
out and if you guys caroline's
in lions and tigers and bears.com
because it's also important um
org it's also important because
animal abuse people whitney animal abuse
there's so much other shit going on in
the world
we children learn how to treat
powerless beings yep from what the way
we treat animals
they only care about animals they don't
care about adults yep yep so they learn
oh we put them in cages that's what
yuval harari says about how
future robots may treat humans right yep
you want a clue
look at how we treat animals yep how do
you think a super intelligence will
treat humans
yeah not the best
what's your note on her on her social
media he wants to be justified
he was like validate me validate me
fucking sparkly and effervescent
and just you just like tell me to pop
some zits on it
you're like you're amy sedaris and your
um rachel ray
and your nigella lawson and your
you want some grit amy poehler and
you're like you're just so
wildly talented at so many things you
remind me of um
my uh dearest friend in the world
jennifer goodwin's sister melissa
goodwin who's an animator
who um animated the end of the female
brain
credits she animated this i'll send it
to you this um
she worked on robot chicken and oh dope
the simpsons and yeah
um you're just so wildly
to house of style which was my favorite
um thing
uh i'm gonna stop saying that on um mtv
which was like how to turn jeans into
napkins how to turn an old pair of jean
shorts into
you know yeah totes haven't heard that
in a hot sack
um cool means
[Laughter]
like you just have so much you're um you
would be like a
lifestyle guru like who's the current
one
the challenge is the one the challenge
for me in
that is that that would require me to be
constantly remembering to document
instead of being present and i spend a
lot of time
just sort of being you're not on your
phone yeah you're not a phone person
i try to be on my phone as little as
possible so that i can be president me
too
so if i had like a professional person
just
follow me around and like do that like
that's the challenge for me is like i
am not obsessed with um my appearance
i'm obsessed with my
experience and um if my
appearance gets in the way of my
experience
the it's the appearance that has to make
you uglier
um i mean i don't know what i look
like in drag oh we dressed up as um
depression-era hobos for a oh yeah
birthday party we did take a picture of
that yeah and then she got shamed for
looking ugly
so she's being insensitive um
uh joe rogan told me about how and we're
wrapping up dave i swear
i swear world war ii german facial
dueling scars
men scars in world war one portraits
so they used to scar uh on purpose
so they would look dope
i always have wanted one of those
through the eyebrow ones yeah
i mean i don't know if you've noticed
but i have a scar
on my face like i have like and part of
it it's so hot
and it's like how did she get that yeah
dueling scars can you pronounce that in
german
schmiessen in german and were seen as a
badge of honor
uh since as early as 1925 alternatively
for mensur
scars fencing scars they were popular
among upper class
austrians and germans to some lesser
extent involved in appendix i just
love how they're like i'm not going to
actually duel
i'm just going to get the cool
dual scar yeah i is going to be
sexy it's like he can protect my
offspring like just like the reminder
that we are animals let's just keep that
in mind when we are mad at people and
hate people and want to
um destroy and humiliate and embarrass
and get ashamed and oh i do i remember
that all the time
that's why i don't get mad at people
animals a lot of people have been hurt
and a lot of people want to make sense
of things that don't make sense and
they put it on other people labyrinths
[Laughter]
it's a good podcast like this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't ride elephants i love you guys
we'll do it again we'll do it again we
have to
[Music]
[Applause]